[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mercredi 12 janvier
voici les titres
un nouveau genre de radar en vallée de
chevreuse à saint lambert des bois ces
trois appareils ont pour vocation
d'endiguer la pollution sonore après
quelques mois d'expérimentation ils
débuteront fin 2022 les verbalisations
des véhicules trop bruyant et des
jardins partagés à elancourt il pourrait
voir le jour en lieu et place des
parcelles de l'association des jardins
familiaux
le projet fait partie du réaménagement
global du quartier des quatre arbres
mais les occupants installés sur place
depuis 1977 ne veulent pas partir
explications et réactions à suivre et
depuis lundi votre pass navigo ne vous
sert plus seulement à emprunter les
transports la carte devient également un
sésame pour obtenir des réductions dans
des centaines de lieux culturels de la
région exemple au château de breteuil à
choisel grégoire de lasteyrie vice
président d'ile-de-france mobilité sera
également notre invité
mais avant de développer ses titres et
cette information qui nous est parvenu
dans l'après-midi l'obligation est du
port du masque en extérieur dans les
yvelines est suspendu une décision du
tribunal administratif de versailles
le juge des référés a admis que même
s'il existait une dégradation est des
conditions et de la contamination colis
de 19 dans le département les données
épidémiologiques concernant les risques
de contamination externe ne justifiait
pas à ce jour une mesure généralisée
c'est à dire l'obligation généralisée du
port du masque en extérieur le juge des
référés juge cette mesure du préfet des
yvelines excessif disproportionné et non
appropriés pour rappel le préfet des
yvelines avait pris cet arrêté le 29
décembre dernier et imposer le port du
masque en extérieur aux yvelinois de
plus de 11 ans un sur l'espace public et
dans les zones urbanisées le juge des
référés a précisé que le p le préfet des
yvelines 1 pourrait tout de même des
limites et des zones d'obligations du
port du masque en extérieur à des lieux
et aussi sur des horaires de forte
affluence ainsi que sur des
manifestations telles que des
regroupements ou des rassemblements sur
la voie publique
[Musique]
c'est le début des soldes d'hiver la
période des prix cassés s'est ouverte ce
mercredi elle se tient jusqu'au 8
février un rendez vous annuel perturbé
en raison du contexte sanitaire
également de l'expansion des ventes
privées tout au long de l'année nous
nous sommes rendus du côté de saint
germain en laye pour interroger des
clients on les écoute au micro de
michael elle me dont
les gens n'ont pas le moral mais bon
c'est pas c'est pas facile c'est pas une
année facile je pense que la période est
un peu morose donc on a mon avis je
pense ses problèmes de se trouver dans
des
confidents dans un endroit clos sa
blessure on y pense j'évite d'aller sur
paris où il ya trop de monde où le
galeries lafayette les grands magasins
comme ça c'est vrai que j'ai dit
j'appréhendais un petit peu bon je vois
que il n'y a pas trop de monde
[Musique]
les ventes privées je dis pas ça
personnellement je suis j'attends
toujours les sols parce que j'ai
l'impression que les sols sont toujours
plus bénéfique et les ventes privées et
du coup dans mon par expérience à tout
ça vaut le coup d'y aller seul dans la
mesure où on peut essayer quand on fait
les soldes les ventes privées par
internet
voilà on ne peut pas essayer les ventes
privées sans ponctuelles pas dans tous
les magasins par tous les articles quand
on évoque le fabuleux seul le terme
soldes on a envie d'y aller voir quand
même citer sans curiosité aussi appris
dans l'actualité également les
enseignants et chefs d'établissements
scolaires appel à la grève pour demain
jeudi une mobilisation pour dénoncer le
protocole sanitaire dans les écoles 75%
de grévistes est une école sur 2 fermée
ce 13 janvier c'est ce qu'annonce le
syndicat snuipp et syndicats
d'enseignants un mouvement important qui
modifie les conditions d'accueil de
votre enfant dans les communes petit
tour non exhaustif à voisins le
bretonneux 39 classes sur 43 des écoles
maternelles et élémentaires seront
fermés la commune et ont un capacité
d'organiser un service d'accueil minimum
un accueil sera cependant possible pour
les enfants des personnels
indispensables à la gestion de crise au
centre des loisirs centres de loisirs du
bois de la garenne de 8h à 19h la ville
de versailles aussi proposera un accueil
pour les enfants de ces mêmes personnels
dans trois pôles la commune invite les
parents d'élèves d'enseignants grévistes
à rechercher un mode de garde alternatif
la ville de saint-germain-en-laye peu
impacté avec 25 places sur 150 organise
un service minimum d'accueil dans quatre
écoles maternelles et trois élémentaire
services mis en place aussi dans la
ville de poissy pour chaque école chaque
école pardon l'accueil est organisée de
7h à 19h conflans sainte honorine
prévoit la fermeture de huit écoles sans
service minimum d'accueil les autres
restent ouvertes mais sans accueil du
matin enfin à guyancourt comme d'autres
communes elle propose cette commune de
guyancourt en accueil pour les enfants
de personnels prioritaires pour lesquels
les classes seront fermées un accueil
qui se rassurer de 7h45 à 18h30 il n'y a
bien sûr pas à l'ensemble des
informations sur lançant des communes du
territoire et pour connaître justement
les prévisions dans votre commune vous
invite à vous rendre sur le site
internet de la commune ou sur ces
réseaux sociaux est d'ailleurs
l'émission 7 8 sociétés de ce soir
abordera la question de la colère dans
les écoles un liés au protocole
sanitaire c'est à 18h30 en direct et
s'est présenté bien sûr par mélanie poké
cette grève elle est terminée les
conducteurs de bus du réseau kéolis ont
bloqué pendant 2 jours les dépôts de
carrières sous poissy et dès que vive
contestation pour dénoncer leurs
conditions de travail et demander aussi
une revalorisation salariale
conséquence presque aucun bus ne
circulait depuis lundi et direction et
syndicats sont finalement parvenus à un
protocole d'accord ce mardi soir ce
protocole d'accord ce mardi soir le
service a pu reprendre le maire de
poissy eddie aït a demandé à
ile-de-france mobilité en remboursement
au moins partiel du passe navigo pour
les voyageurs impactés
[Musique]
c'est une start-up saint-quentinoise qui
a réalisé 170 millions de chiffre
d'affaires
mais avant cela on va parler de cette
start up all tricks 1 qui s'est
développée grandement en 2021 d'abord la
suite d'une histoire entre la vallée de
chevreuse et les pollutions sonores
après trois premiers radars placés en
2019 à des fins d'étude et de pédagogie
on passe désormais à l'étape suivante à
saint lambert des bois une commune de la
vallée de chevreuse celle de nouveaux
tests qui aboutiront à des
verbalisations fin 2022 reportage de
bixente manet santisteva des 2 mathilde
de franco
une expérimentation de trois à six mois
vient de débuter à saint lambert des
bois trois radars sonore appelés radars
hydre sont testés et est talonné au
niveau de la rd 46 ils sont fabriqués
par ac om micro db et bruitparif le
principe c'est vraiment de d'identifier
avec précision le niveau sonore des
véhicules à leur passage et lorsque ça x
est d'un certain seuil qui n'est pas
encore fixée qu'il le sera par arrêté
ministériel dans les semaines qui
viennent dans ce cas là on transmettra
le dossier d'infraction c'est le premier
radar ténor avisés de troll sanctions
135 euros damende c'est le prix qu'il
faudra payer en cas d'infraction une
seconde phase de test avec verbalisation
prévus fin 2022 branche
saint lambert des mois fait partie des
trois sites retenus pour cette
expérimentation la vallée de chevreuse
est un lieu bien connu pour ses bruits
de moteurs excessif
[Applaudissements]
en sur la d 91 il ya un petit hameau qui
s'appelle labrosse qui est très impacté
par par ce phénomène de bruit il ya onze
mille véhicules qui passent par jour à
cet endroit là plus le week-end les les
motos et les voitures aussi bruyante la
pollution sonore entre engine chroniques
troubles du sommeil est responsable d'au
moins douze mille décès prématurés
chaque année en europe
l'association des jardins familiaux à
elancourt inquiète pour son avenir
installé près du parc des sports guy
boniface depuis plus de 40 ans les
soixante six parcelles pourraient
disparaître dans le cadre d'un projet
global de refonte du quartier à la
concertation est en cours la mairie
entend apporter des propositions mais le
dialogue semble au point mort wilfried
richy et célia gars tsongor
nouveaux logements nouveaux commerces
nouveau commissariat le secteur des
quatre arbres connaîtra dans les
prochaines années un profond remaniement
à elancourt en vaste chantier qui
pourrait entraîner un déménagement de
l'association des jardins familiaux
présente ici sur ce terrain public
depuis 1977 avec ses soixante six
parcelles
une phase de concertation est en cours
avec la population mais pour
l'association la municipalité aurait
déjà fait son choix les jardiniers se
sont aperçus quand même depuis 2018 que
la municipalité ici si vous voulez en
vendée les terrains à des promoteurs
pour construire des logements pour donc
ramener de l'argent évidemment pour
réaliser des dépenses municipales
si on a réussi à supprimer d'abord les
jardins familiaux on a réussi
l'opération donc nous voulons rester sur
place et cultivé au coeur des
inquiétudes une délibération présentée
en décembre dernier lors du conseil
municipal avec un projet de jardin
partagé là où il ya une mauvaise
interprétation ses parents pour nous une
volonté de détruire de supprimer les
jardins famille n'a jamais été notre
idée nous sommes ouverts à toutes
discussions monsieur le maire à cause de
les rencontrer aujourd'hui on voit bien
qu'il ya une attente une demande une
jardins familiaux de jardins partagés
également sans que les avant-toits son
mandat en attente et notre affection
elle porte aussi sur sa septième il n'y
a pas que cette association kirwan
existait il ya 12 heures pourquoi raids
similaires gantois il faut qu'on prenne
en compte leurs demandes et leurs
besoins une réunion des changes est
annoncée dans les prochaines semaines
dès que les conditions sanitaires le
permettront la refonte complète du
quartier pourrait ensuite débuté en 2026
on va parler à présent de cette start-up
saint-quentinoise qui a réalisé 170
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
en 2021 holt rixe est spécialisée dans
le e-commerce du vélo et des activités
extérieures
2008 cette société continue de grandir
avec l'ouverture d'un magasin à
coignières et une stratégie orientée
vers l'économie circulaire explication
dans ce sujet de nicolas d'andré de
bixente mais rien senti sebban elle
vient d'ouvrir son nouveau magasin de
1200 m² à coignières la start up all
tricks a enregistré une croissance de
30% en 2021 avec six boutiques en france
elle réalise plus de la majorité de son
chiffre d'affaires en ligne 2021 une
année durant laquelle elle a orienté sa
stratégie vers l'économie circulaire du
vélo on a la chance d'être sur des
produits qui sont durables par
définition à vannes oc s'est entretenu
ça peut durer longtemps on s'est quand
même un peu dommage en proposition de
valeur auprès de nos utilisateurs de
leur dire historiquement on vous vend
que du neuf on sait faire que ça alors
qu'on est capable de créer la boucle
l'engagement dans l'économie circulaire
de sept entreprises du e-commerce est
passé par le rachat du site troc vélo en
février 2021 une plateforme de vente de
produits cycliste entre particuliers
c'est aussi le lancement du programme
seconde life là on vient racheter des
produits à des particuliers ou à des
professionnels sur un vélo notamment ça
peut être d'autres produits qui
nécessitent une intervention technique
le changement d'une batterie le
changement des pneus le changement de la
chaîne et des cassettes avant de pouvoir
être revendus là pour le tout
directement par deux fois pour engager
une nouvelle vie d'après les premiers
chiffres dole tricks la plateforme troc
vélo en possible plus de 50 millions
d'euros de transactions par an
[Musique]
si vous empruntez quotidiennement les
transports il est votre sésame pour vous
rendre partout en ile-de-france votre
pass navigo vous ne le savez peut-être
pas et depuis lundi également un pass
culturel grâce à la carte vous pouvez
obtenir des réductions dans des
centaines de lieux de la région
francilienne on en parle avec mon invité
par visioconférence grigor de lasteyrie
bonsoir
vice président d'ile-de-france mobilité
également délégué spécial de la région
aux mobilités durables et j'ajoute que
vous êtes aussi le maire de la ville de
palaiseau dans le département de
l'essonne alors dans les yvelines 21
sites sont concernés par cette actualité
dont le château de breteuil à choisel
mathilde franco et nicolas d'andry s'y
sont rendus mais fermez votre pass
navigo vous permet d'accéder à des lieux
culturels dans les yvelines 21
exactement aujourd'hui on se trouve au
château de breteuil gimont pass navigo
on va voir quel avantage je peux avoir
[Applaudissements]
alors pour ma part c'est la première
fois que je viens au château de breteuil
à choisel c'est la première fois que je
découvre du coup jean emmanuel ou est ce
qu on est déjà pour commencer dans
quelle pièce on situe alors nous sommes
ici dans la grande galerie c'est dire la
halle gauche du château le château a été
construit il ya 400 ans et il s'est
toujours transmis depuis quatre siècles
au sein de la même famille il y est donc
génération après génération ou une
accumulation de beaucoup de souvenirs de
famille que vous pouvez découvrir au fil
de la visite est ici dans cette galerie
de portraits il ya notamment les
ministres qu'il ya eu dans la famille
breteuil qui ont servi les rois de
france et il ya de magnifiques portraits
royaux également de louis saez de louis
xviii du grand dauphin et vous verrez
d'autres portraits royaux également dans
les autres pièces du château quels sont
les autres pièces qu'on peut visiter il
ya des salons avec de magnifiques
tapisseries et puis au premier étage
tout un circuit historique avec des
personnages de cire du musée grévin qui
font qui raconte l'histoire de la
famille à travers l'histoire de france
et il ya comme ça grâce à grévin
plusieurs breteuil qui reçoivent louis
saez louis xviii marcel proust voltaire
une succession de petites scènes
historiques ce qui rend la visite très
vivante et très ludique et des jeunes
enfants apprécient énormément parce que
c'est beaucoup moins le sens évidemment
qu'une succession de meubles et puis
même pour les adultes c'est très parlant
de voir louis xviii par exemple dans son
fauteuil roulant sont un vrai intérêt
plutôt que de voir le fauteuil vide et
donc là on est au rez de chaussée
ensuite on va aller tâche pour commencer
ça alors allons-y c'est parti
[Musique]
et donc aujourd'hui moi je visite le
château de breteuil grâce à mon taf
navigo
comment est-ce que c'est venu vous en
avez discuté avec la région et bien
la région nous a proposé de mettre en
place un système de partenariat qui
offre aux visiteurs ayant le pass navigo
une réduction dans différents lieux
culturels au monument de breteuil a
accepté de faire partie de ce
partenariat est donc en venant avec
votre passé navigo visiter breteuil vous
bénéficiez automatiquement du tarif
réduit c'est à dire environ 2 euros de
moins sur tous les billets enfant ou
adulte et donc là on arrive au cabinet
des trésors oui c'est ce qu'on appelle
le cabinet trésor parce que il y à fait
magnifique table au centre de la pièce
dans cette table c'est le trésor
familial
alors elle a été vendue au louvre il y a
cinq ans mais nous allons faire cette
magnifique réplique pour continuer à
raconter l'histoire de ce bijou et
surtout le rôle médiatique du baron de
breteuil sous louis saez qui par sa
diplomatie a mis fin à la guerre de
succession de bavière une guerre qui
allait embraser toute l'europe centrale
et cette table et bien fait le cadeau
qu'il avait reçue pour avoir rétabli la
paix eh bien merci beaucoup jean
emmanuel pour cette visite très
instructive du château de venir à vis de
nous avoir accueillis à watten voilà le
château de breteuil à choisel parmi la
centaine de possibilités en
ile-de-france 21,6 dans les unes qu'on
va boire dans un instant sa fiche et
grégoire de lasteyrie qui est avec moi
dix présidents et d'ile-de-france
mobilité pourquoi ouvrir ce pass navigo
à des avantages culturels quels sont les
objectifs
l'objectif c'est d'offrir la culture ou
plus comme en nombre pour ouvrir la
culture au plus grand nombre c'est
évidemment c'est plus de 300 lieux sur
l'île de france qui depuis lundi sont
accessibles à des tarifs réduits ou un
des grands avantages pour le pass navigo
c'est un objectif
de pouvoir rajouter en permanence de
nouveaux sites dans votre département
dans votre beau département vous avez vu
château de breteuil vous avez le france
nature à elancourt aussi vous avez de
nombreux cinémas vous avez des choses
après si vous avez des choses à proposer
le château de rambouillet je vais pas
tous les citer mais vraiment de nombreux
lieux vous pouvez aller l'objectif c'est
que pascal gigot cascoin pas ce qu'il ya
de plus en plus de services associés sur
se passe là on parle de culture ensemble
et mais peut-être que vous le savez déjà
mais quand vous avez un pass navigo vous
avez deux trajets de covoiturage
quotidiennement qui vous seront offerts
par ile-de-france mobilité et vous
pouvez avoir accès également à des
parkings relais gratuits sans recours à
votre vélo soit en votre voiture vous
voir mieux vous déplacez vous voyez le
pass navigo s'est pas uniquement quelque
chose pour de monter dans le rer ou dans
le métro en bus c'est en fait beaucoup
plus de choses aujourd'hui avec un pass
de vigo et c'est important aussi pour et
lefranc mobilité de donner en quelque
sorte ce coup de pouce aussi à ces lieux
culturels on le sait qu'ils ont souffert
à cause de cette crise sanitaire qui
sont moins fréquentés aussi ya moins de
touristes et ils sont moins fréquenter
ces lieux culturels
écoutez c'est gagnant pour tout le monde
c'est gagnant pour le détenteurs du pass
navigo qui a accès à des avantages dans
305 quasiment 350 plus franciliens
aujourd'hui six gagnants pour les lieux
culturels qui ont plus de guides
puissent également possible de france
mobilité parce que régulièrement pour
aller sur ces différents lieux pas vous
allez prendre les transports en commun
et nous notre objectif c'est que le
maximum de franciliens ils sont 4
millions aujourd'hui à détenir un pass
navigo utilisent les transports en
commun et plus de 300 sites qui sont
associés à cette initiative est ce que
les partenariats on était facile à
monter ce que les lieux culturels ont
facilement accepté l'initiative
il ya un vrai engouement de la part des
partenaires pour pouvoir participer on a
fait ça très rapidement c'était un
engagement de valérie pécresse lors des
élections régionales de juin dernier
vous voyez il est mis en oeuvre début
2000 22 il est mis en oeuvre quelques
mois plus tard et on y est on continue à
être en contact avec des nouveaux lieux
le pour pouvoir continuer à enrichir
pour savoir quels sont les lieux sur
lequel vous avez accès grâce à votre
pass navigo vous allez sur le site
d'ile-de-france mobilité vous n'appelez
pas cela vidéo culture sur sur votre
moteur de recherche de tomber sur
l'occiput de force mobilité vous avez
une carte interactive qui géologue et ce
très précisément les lieux sur lesquels
vous allez allez avoir des différents
avantages ça cet hélico qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran alors petit peu
concrètement y accédons à compris les
détenteurs de pass navigo il ya quelques
exceptions c'est bien ça alors ces
détenteurs de pass navigo que ce soit 1
passe et budo mensuel ou annuel vous
allez pouvoir avoir accès à ces assez à
ces lieux c'est vraiment les secousses
et le passe navigo classiques tels que
vous pourrez connaître si vous avez une
carte liberté plus ou si vous avez
un avis oui vous avez une caste liberté
liberté plus ou des vidéos vive la
liberté alors vous n'êtes vous n'êtes
pas éligible c'est vraiment les passes
navigo et d'au moins su aller et à nu
mais ça veut dire combien de personnes
environ sont éligibles en ile de france
4 millions de personnes aujourd'hui
qu'ils sont détenteurs de cette carte
vous voyez c'est une grande partie des
fonctions et vous disiez tout à l'heure
alors il ya déjà une grosse offre un
plus de 300 sites en sites il ya 147
cinéma notamment mais aussi des grands
musées d'été à des salles de spectacles
des monuments des festivals aussi un il
ya l'accès à des festivals et des
événements qui a qui est prévu vous
lisez s'amener peut-être à grandir il ya
toujours un travail peut-être pour
agrandir cette liste de sites
actuellement sais pas peut-être c'est
certain l'objectif c'est de continuer à
ajouter des lieux ça c'est vraiment une
liste dynamique on a voulu partir avec
eux nos premiers partenaires qui étaient
extrêmement motivés pour être tout de
suite dès le départ dans l'opération
mais avec la région ile de france et
avec une défense mobilité on continue à
enrichir cette liste dans les prochaines
semaines dans les prochains mois donc
vraiment il faut 2 n'hésitez pas à vous
connecter régulièrement sur les sites
pour voir les nouvelles choses que le
tour suivant et puis pourquoi pas vous
dire que ce week-end c'est l'occasion
peut-être d'aller voir la philharmonie
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
pompidou à paris où toutes les
merveilles qu'il ya dans votre
département le maire de palaiseau que je
suis est heureux parce que juste à côté
de ma commune avec une machine qu'il ya
un très bel opéra donc là on a aussi des
avantages grâce au pass navigo est le
théâtre de longjumeau qui est bien
connue de nombre de franciliens et
toutes les possibilités on le disait un
sur le site internet d'ile-de-france
mobilité mrc grégoire de lasteyrie
d'avoir été avec nous merci beaucoup
pour une soirée et je le rappelle vice
président d'ile-de-france mobilité cette
information avant de refermer le journal
la 96e édition de cette classique devait
se tenir dans la nuit du 29 au 30
janvier la marche paris versailles mans
a été annulée par l'association
organisatrice la hesse mantaise deuxième
année consécutive en deux ans liée au
contexte sanitaire 4500 personnes
devaient y participer elles seront
intégralement remboursés l'an passé la
marche s'était déroulé finalement
virtuel avec l'accomplissement de 10000
km cumulés par démarche individuelle sur
deux jours les organisateurs
réfléchissent à proposer la même chose
pour cette année voilà c'est la fin de
ce journal merci de votre fidélité belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]